they need for more efficient returns of
those not entitles to say in the
European Union was reiterated and there
was broad agreement to mainstream
returns across all relevant policy areas
as regards solidarity the Dublin system
does not cater for scenarios of
exceptional circumstances as the
experience has taught us that we cannot
rely entirely on an ad hoc measures to
ensure a workable policy cycle 10 crime
priorities were identified including the
fight against cybercrime facilitating in
legal migration document fraud and
Firearms on counterterrorism and the
sharing of information between military
and law enforcement earlier today we had
a joint discussion between defense and
Home Affairs ministers on how to
strengthen the EU section on
counterterrorism by enhancing military
and law enforcement cooperation and
information exchange ensuring stability
in our larger neighbourhood will not
only contribute to reducing migration
flows but also to diminishing some of
the root causes of terrorism our
internal and external security policies
are closely interlinked two elements are
essential first increasing information
sharing between our internal and
external work on security and second
improving our cooperation with
international stakeholders international
actors the recent cyber attack is a
stark reminder not sort of the magnitude
of the challenge but also how such
security and criminal threats come in
many forms and how our response has to
adapt today we also discussed the Dublin
reform and solidarity
in our Asylum policy unfortunately one
year after the Commission made its
proposal to improve doubling there is
still no consensus in the council